how's it going bros my name is Pam bass
I'm sorry that I keep screaming the
barrels out no it scares a lot a brooch
you just need to man up what can I say
anyway we're looking for a house it's
supposed to be by the end of a row there
hello Jennifer hi your painting I love
you so much I know I'm pretty fat but
you should love me because I have a lot
of skin I'm hot hey what is this all
right Oh daddy buddy naked guys I guess
he wasn't really teleporting bowels oh
you scared of lamb oh my god huh get the
[ __ ] out I hate barrels so [ __ ] much
I don't even know where I'm going I'm
totally disoriented okay look at that
Bell
where-where-where
[Applause]
I don't get what's going on
holy [ __ ] penises now that Valley why
you looking at me with your penis
holy penis what is he doing oh I'm just
gonna go oh no not again please oh my
god
no stop bow stop funny it's not funny it
was funny the first time maybe actually
it wasn't funny another tank get out of
your bout I hate you more than I hate
not don't dance in front of me bath oh
no I might uh I it's gotta be [ __ ]
here I can just taste the [ __ ]
battles smell the bass bass yeah
stop scaring me get oh hey that's what
you get down that's what your [ __ ]
yet that was awesome alright let's go
here I think we found these the puzzle
hello penny I waited a long time for you
I heard you screaming out here are you
safe you're safe now with me pity you
know I haven't been feeling stupid I'm
sick and tired of you never listening
you never share more pity you never know
[ __ ]
you know why you know what now I'm to be
good now I'm deaf cat right you're right
I'm gonna share more on you how about
dad camera act people Oh
why would you do that miss hey I got a
key all right sweetie huggy I'm sorry
please I was just praying I love you
come here I just wanna hug you all night
long eating nothing gay wear anything
I'm totally straight I mean I'm a chance
even though I don't have a penis
anything like that yeah right whatever
you say sure mr. Shaye's crazy freakin
crazy yeah you like my teacher by the
way finally it's all right like it
wasn't Spreadshirt eyebrows get the [ __ ]
out of here Jesus Christ let me talk
about my patient all right let's see
what you mute again huh
you go for the [ __ ] Christmas that's
what to get battle that's what you
[ __ ] get let's find more barrels
let's [ __ ] the whole life up all right
no don't do it
I don't care get out of here bells are
doesn't work hey you can never read me
pity you can never beat me I am shut up
arrow oh that's what to get barrels that
you a thief or [ __ ] yet smartest the
best mother ever
alright let's keep on trying hey another
one
alright I'm saving you our now payday
yeah I don't care okay doesn't like that
it's kind of
commenting this is to throw you out of
the house how doesn't might get it hey
why don't you focus in on the game and
the story I'm sorry I'm talking to the
barrel here Jesus Christ all right I'll
leave you with your barrel buddies
you're lucky this is your lucky day
funny mr. Bach
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's come on well you see hi this
is nobody's up at it it's got five got
it blam oh my god okay here's the city
huh oh okay
let's hide here camouflage with itself
Orton thank you guys
don't you deaf I can't tell me where I
am anyway I am or why I keep saying that
all right you see hey so cool it goes
oops forget okay all right but if you
come in here ah ah stop please I just
want to I have a teleport mega guy
I'm one of you guys I swear all right
all right all right when he comes here
good all right come at me bro he's right
behind me go oh my leg penis
thanks [ __ ] penis hi babe
this cannot be healthy
holy [ __ ] we made it holy [ __ ] penis
others rats in here that's disgusting
hey I I love I got a lot of comments in
the last episode saying I don't loot
well enough so here we go there's some
bags books
oh thank god I just want the loot this
hey tinderbox I should just ignore it
[ __ ] witty bros because he always here
werster Jamie Foxx best impression ever
I'm sorry I don't know and I don't I'm
sorry I was just kidding I feel like I
offended hey who's the King now pity
who's the king I'm the king what'd he
talk about what different if you have it
sorry alright hey let's make it nice and
cozy for missus yeah you like that you
like that mr. chair yeah I like that a
lot and I don't trust you
get out of here
all right we should or should we pick
the first all right there's the only
ones are are you ready for this browse
all right
I think we're ready to go what oh no we
don't have the [ __ ] key
all right let's sign the freaking key
then oh this door here I totally missed
it all right hey telephone [ __ ] yeah
how you doing
where's the follow where is he tell me
where did you put sathana why am I
talking to your penis that is your face
all right I don't like his [ __ ] like it
stays like he feels too satisfied I
don't like that hey what're you doing
try to hide from me huh huh I try to
hide for me huh no yeah all right that's
obvious that that is for my father to
the mayor don't mind if I take a pic
I'm sorry mr. chairman all right the
letter reads dear mr. mayor good evening
sir
my name is ale is Jackson I live in
mansion beyond town that's how we all
live here for about 57 years in a large
way been ruling the people however I
reckon for you my wife Libby she's a
fine lady baby Jackson has been oh no
it's just a shame this is not a typical
murder you see sir had had cure I don't
take this the wrong way allow me to
explain I've ever seen you know I
haven't the Royal Army of developing
chemical free Hina Latin animam
unfortunately my life was getting
between my researchers and all the time
I just had to do it he was about to tell
me the world about some product I go and
I heard I was like its lad neither I'm
here we're talking lion and them I had
to kill her I'm close to found his
siblings and I mean Latin Adam is more
version that and picture legal and stuff
and my son dead again in Jack's room I
had nephron being willing to offer more
and then I was like Jesse Jackson
then we took the mayor's key and then we
could not open this let's try it and
open this it did not work all right
that's cool
how did I miss you I lost Bailey I am
capitalization Stephano all right I was
watching that telefónica guy if you had
to you if I hadn't been watching in here
with a fricking telepods it right in
your face
Hey all right Stephano I'm sorry I can't
bring you with me but you stay here with
mr. sheriff mr. shirt doesn't like me I
know
thank you I appreciate what are you
doing leaving me with this freaking
[ __ ] all right we have to go yeah
let's just do it that's just
I had a Red Bull before this episode I
don't forget down all right this is
focus Jesus Christ airs are obnoxious up
racing you dance this guy's ever M oh my
god I've been walking for hours feels
like hours it's probably more like
seconds but it could be on no it's never
what if I take a shortcut and that's the
pretty pi way ladies and gentlemen all
right Wow all right let's go
Wow they just make you go downstairs for
another [ __ ] loading screen that's
not you can pick it up that would be
awesome
all right thank you oil thank you so
much
all right let's do the 360 click that's
how I roll how about that how about that
how about that how about that how about
that how about that how about that how
about it how about it how about that how
about that how about that how about that
how about that how about sorry
oh no I don't like this one [ __ ]
second bit bucks I'm sorry have to test
if this works
black
I don't like this stop wasting your okay
don't waste it
just this part cuz it's really dark and
scary I don't appreciate all right Oh No
why did I tell you about alright let me
give me give me a rock
I don't trust you I don't trust you
either buddy you're not my buddy I was
just kidding I guess we're going here
first I wanted to do the hula to lid off
the start so many doors have might as
well do it sisqó oh [ __ ] oh my god
all right hello
that's disturbing it no no person
deserves that
not even teleporting naked guys not sure
how he keeps his own that way but I'm
having my I watch for you brush their
[ __ ] cow
spin the wheel baby alright spinning in
let's see if I can progress here spin oh
yeah hey there lady cow who a potato
that's amazing I didn't know that I'm
spinning yep I spun that wheel run it
good hey what's down here oh I can't go
down here alright good
don't really want to go down there I
know why that teleport down there No why
would they do that
why won't they open the mysteries of my
life oh well let's pick out another cord
all right barrels do you think you can
just hang out here in the corner I know
what you doing you're trying to blend in
with the environment all right oh no bro
what did they do it to you why would
they know no oh no it was yeah hey
might've oh yeah
oh no I don't like that stuff
I don't like that song one [ __ ] bit
alright let's go ahead no I don't want
to share cell with the teleporting naked
guy okay I had the machine room key and
he's coming here all right this is cap
here don't you dare [ __ ] tell them
I'll kill you even though you're
probably already dead
I can I had underneath the bed I would
totally hide him
all right we're camping with Abed I am
totally protected by this men or Stuckey
becomes my tells me hello no the ladies
I have like that it's cold out
all right he's leaving go that's right
run [ __ ] run
all right it's go it's not gone [ __ ] all
right he's gone
I picked the machine room key I don't
know where he goes
let's keep on trying barrels probably
over here I don't like this one bit
I don't like this one [ __ ] bit saying
that yeah mam mam alpha man where's the
attic by the way how's this model let's
call the attic is an attic more like a
basement
alright I think now we can go here after
I picked up that painting box a [ __ ]
you up with boughs and another bow all
right I'm gonna end it here bros if she
enjoyed since we didn't like and
favorite super gothic more bro - hey
account already and I'll see you
tomorrow but then go through that door
more scary stuff will probably happen so
don't mean it and stuff ok I can't
believe all the forgetting stuff
alright
[Music]
now it back in the Attic
oh oh no I ain't gotta just that happy
I'm there